s'abonner
accueillir?
besoin après deux épidémies de virus
Pensée à nos frères et soeurs
nous avons pensé que pouvons-nous faire
ce que veulent nos frères
Dans notre mosquée, ils apportent, ils partent et
nos frères dans le besoin
ils prennent les choses autant qu'ils en ont besoin
s'abonner
Ouais d'accord d'accord je dois dire maintenant
Il y avait aussi la bienvenue L'homme travaille à vide
j'allais à leur travail aussi
nous avons une vie mais le revenu est social allemand
ils ne donnent pas d'aide de l'aide, nous sommes mauvais
Bien
s'abonner
Un grand merci à ceux qui ont aidé
Que Dieu vous bénisse, les oignons sont durs aussi
c'est pas l'heure de toute façon notre boulot 139a ne marche pas
Je jure que c'est très bon, oui c'est ça
Nous entrons dans le mois de Ramadan, la personne qui a fait ça
Que Dieu bénisse ceux qui ont contribué
je suis assis pouvez-vous me dire
s'abonner